Ah, subthemes. They can make your deck better, or
they can make your deck worse, and either of those
two might be a desirable outcome depending
on what you look for in a game of Magic:
the Gathering. Hi there, I’m Alex, and today
I’m here to tell you about a passion of mine:
making decks do more things. Most EDH decks will
have a theme—Merfolk, tokens, on-attack triggers,
and so forth—and this is a nice place to start
in getting a deck to do something. However,
eventually that one theme might start to
get a little boring, and your eyes might
begin to wander. That on-attack trigger card
makes tokens, can I play harder into that? I
really like this zombie creature that makes me
discard cards, can I make my deck focus more on
discard? This ETB creature searches up legendary
cards, I wonder how that might fit into my blink
deck. And this makes sense! Having your deck
do more stuff, have more textured play paths,
produce more unexpected results—all of
this will be desirable to a lot of players,
particularly players who have already played a
lot with more linear styles of deck. So here,
I’m going to be making a little guide on how to
answer the sorts of questions I mentioned earlier
about specific cards you’re finding yourself
transfixed by, and at the end you might have
an exciting arsenal of brand new questions to
probe your deck with. With that said, let’s begin.
Assuming you’re not trying to obliterate your
deck’s consistency, a good place to start in
expanding your deck’s synergy universe is
going to be what I’ll call fulcrum cards.
This is a thing that naturally
ties together multiple subthemes,
and it can take a variety of different forms,
but typically comes in the form of a payoff from
one theme that rewards another. Throne of Geth
ties together artifact sacrifice and counters,
Displacer Kitten ties together the
flicker and spellslinger archetypes,
and Strength from the Fallen ties together
enchantments and creature-stuffed graveyards,
with a resulting payoff that can work well
for a power-matters deck. These are pretty
clear examples of fulcrum cards, but there are a
lot of other examples that are less obvious but
absolutely there if you go looking. Professional
Facebreaker rewards a board of evasive creatures
with some artifact tokens that can crack for mana,
Quicksmith Genius rewards artifacts entering with
rummages that can feed graveyard strategies, and
Squee Dubious Monarch rewards a stocked graveyard
with a reanimated attacker that generates tokens.
Why were all of those examples red three drops,
you might ask? No particular reason, but you
should definitely put them all in the same
deck. Regardless, all of these cards represent
points of fusion between different archetypes,
connective glue that involves setup for one
archetype turning into payoff for another.
An important consideration when thinking about
this sort of card is the floor of the effect.
I’m stat-brained so I’d be thinking about
maybe the 25th percentile game for a card,
but basically what we’re wondering is how the card
will feel in a subpar situation, where it’s not
living up to our wildest dreams. For some of the
cards I mentioned earlier, the floor is pretty
high. Professional Facebreaker will usually manage
to generate at least a couple treasures, and
Displacer Kitten can at least serve as protection
if no juicy ETB creatures are present. For others,
the floor might be a lot lower, though. Dross
Scorpion is a card I run in one of my decks
that works as a fulcrum point between artifact
creatures hitting graveyard and tap effects,
but this card could easily end up being a poorly
statted creature with a single untap on death,
and that’s important to keep in mind. It gets
even worse for noncreature spells—in my most
recent deck review, one of my supporters was
trying to integrate a small-ish Astral Slide
flicker package into a deck, and unfortunately
without any cycling cards in hand that card is
just a three mana textless enchantment. This
is where a bit of discernment is necessary—it’s
important to figure out what works as a minor part
of a deck, and what has no business being outside
a deck that doesn’t heavily support it, due to
its low floor. As a related example of this,
I’ve had a handful of people suggest Rhet-Tomb
Mystic for my Astral Slide deck. At first glance
this might make sense—I’m playing a deck trying
to cycle cards, this card gives all my creatures
cycling, and it’s a Wizard to top it all off,
grabbable with my Wizardcycling cards. However,
the issue with adding a card like this is that—at
its floor—it will always consume a card slot that
could have gone to an ETB creature or some
card draw or a card that itself has cycling,
and then how high do you think the ceiling
will be in a deck where over 40% of the
creatures already have cycling? It looks
good at first, and I’m sure it’s great in
a more general graveyard deck, but once we
do the floor/ceiling calculation it becomes
clear that this little bird gets mogged by
a Merfolk Looter in this particular deck.
As you might have guessed, a major factor in the
floor/ceiling discussion is the amount of deck
space required to support a particular card.
A lot of possible fulcrum cards might already
be within your synergy family of choice, and
might create resources that are already useful
to what you’re doing even if they theoretically
might tie naturally into a different subtheme.
We can see this with the treasure example earlier,
where treasures are just a naturally useful tool
for basically all decks. This stands in contrast
to something like a Doorkeeper in an Arcades the
Strategist deck—how do you make target player
milling feel useful for a theme that usually wins
through combat damage and doesn’t traditionally
utilize the graveyard very much? I’m sure plenty
of people have done it, but it requires more
divergence from the traditional Arcades gameplan
than a lot of other defenders payoffs, and will
likely demand more deck space to be any good as
a result. Another angle for thinking about deck
space could be to consider how closely interlinked
two different themes are to one another. Sometimes
there will be a whole bunch of fulcrum cards for
a particular set of two themes, with one I’ve
utilized in the past being artifacts and ETB
effects. Thought Monitor, Conjurer’s Closet, Myr
Battlesphere, Mimic Vat, the Mages—there’s a whole
lot of options there, and if you’re playing a
bunch of these your two-theme deck experience
might end up feeling decently compact despite
its somewhat mechanically broad nature. However,
many other sets of two themes have dramatically
less innate shared DNA. If I’m trying to make a
deck that combines cast-from-exile and
landfall, well there are two landfall
cards with exile-you-may-play text, and there are
also cards that reward playing lands from exile
in addition to casting spells which work well
for us, and then if we dive into “from anywhere
other than your hand” effects as well we might
find some roundabout synergies in other landfall
cards such as Courser of Kruphix and Hedron
Crab, among others. Hopefully you can see what
I’m getting at here—sometimes you’re just gonna
have a bit of a hard time combining two themes.
Now, does this mean that you shouldn’t smash
together two very different synergy families? No!
Artifacts + ETB, Tokens + 1/1 counters—these have
been done tens of thousands of times before for
good reason, but you always have the opportunity
to do something different, something unique,
something more specifically suited to who you
are as a player. What you should do, though,
is know that’s what you’re doing, figure out why
you’re doing that, and then figure out a plan of
action based on what your goals are. Let’s say
you’re building an initiative deck with a heavy
emphasis on legendary permanents in general and
the background enchantments in particular. Cool,
a bit tricky, but there are some possible points
of connection here. Next, it’s important to figure
out the reason for building the deck, because
that will affect the decisions you make. If you’re
trying to build a decent bracket 3 deck with this
set of restrictions as a challenge, you’ll want
to dial in hard on the points of cohesion, and
consider ways you can get the different elements
to come together more often. Maybe we run partner
commanders to get full use out of Dungeon Delver,
and pick colors that offer the most utility in
putting together our gameplan. If we decide that
Dungeon Delver is a key card for us, maybe we
add some cards like Enlightened Tutor, Muddle
the Mixture, and a couple other helpful tutors in
whatever colors we end up in so that we can get
that card more often, and then maybe we pair that
with other useful cards that fit the same tutoring
restrictions. If we have the goal of getting the
most mechanically fluid version of initiative
legendaries, there are some cool decision paths
we can run down, and the end result will likely
be a very unique bracket 3 deck. Some people
might worry that tutors will homogenize the play
experience of a deck, but this won’t necessarily
be true—card selection tools like filtering
spells and conditional tutors will reduce the play
pattern variance of a deck, but if you add them to
a deck that would otherwise have extreme levels
of play pattern variance due to having a lot
of moving parts, you’ll likely end up in a place
that is still very fresh and dynamic to play with.
Now let’s say we’re building with a different
goal: we’re just trying to have a good time,
and are likely aiming for more of a laid back,
bracket 2 style deck. This is also a very valid
goal, and honestly it’s a pretty fantastic reason
to make a deck that might be just a little bit
mechanically dubious. If your starting point is
a naturally slower-paced political mechanic like
initiative, and if you’re introducing extra
layers of synergy rather than filling your
deck with high quality staple creatures, you’re
going to end up with something that plays quite
well at lower power tables. You’ll want to
make sure you’re running enough filtering so
that your deck functions and so that you’re
having fun throughout the whole process,
but the play pattern of a deck that gradually
filters for different elements of its cool,
funky gameplan is one that is perfect for a
bracket 2 game in both pace and nature. As
a final note here, playing at a lower power table
is also a great place for a somewhat mechanically
disjointed deck because incentives align perfectly
on what sorts of vegetables you should be running,
particularly removal. Lower power opponents
won’t require all the best removal the game
has to offer, and this means you can do something
that’s already nice to do: run some of the higher
mana options with added utility for your synergy
families. My bracket 2 incubators deck has 16
cards I’ve categorized as interaction which is
a decent number, but if I click through these
on the Archidekt page literally all of them do
something else for the deck. This is nice for
keeping a mechanically messy deck from feeling too
bad, and it also lets me play with cards that are
a bit more unique within the commander format. Is
Spread the Sickness the best removal this game has
to offer? Definitely not, but it feels immensely
at home in this deck, and I wouldn’t dare cut it.
Thanks for watching! I’m going to be at MagicCon
Vegas in just a week or so, and I’ll be hosting
a panel along with The Trinket Mage and a
couple friends of the podcast. Come watch that,
or get a sticker, or just say hi, whatever floats
your boat. If you want to support what I do here,
you can grab some high quality sleeves from
dragonshield, affiliate link in description,
or you can support me more directly
through Patreon or a YouTube membership.
These lovely people, some of whom are onscreen
now, help let me keep doing what I do here,
and they also receive bonus videos from
me once per month or so, plus a chance
at a deck review every three months. If
you want to join this illustrious crowd,
the links and/or buttons to do so are
probably on your screen somewhere!